the aviation sector is on the brink of a
crisis
its future is in limbo as the world
moves towards
decarbonization planes are currently
only responsible for two to three
percent of the world's carbon dioxide
emissions
but that's expected to rise to 25 by
2050
most major polluters have clear
technology pathways to a cleaner future
the automotive industry has batteries
and electric motors
the shipping industry has a range of
potential alternative clean fuels to
choose from
our electric grids are rapidly investing
in solar
and wind and future nuclear energy
projects are being researched
intensively there is still plenty of
work to do
but the path ahead for these sectors
have been surveyed
and marked however the aviation industry
has no clear way forward for replacing
kerosene
and if the aviation sector can't find
answers to this problem
it's projected that with the continued
growth of passenger numbers
and the expected decarbonization across
other industries
that it could represent as much as 25
of total worldwide emissions by 2050
to understand this problem and potential
technologies that we could see
in the future we first need to
understand the current state of aviation
fuel
today nearly all jet engines use
kerosene
but internal combustion turbine engines
are not
actually that picky about what fuel they
consume
gas-powered turbines power grids all
over the world
and many of them are being converted to
run on bioethanol
early jet engines were powered by mostly
gasoline
if it burns hot and can be pumped into a
combustion chamber
chances are it can drive a turbine but
it's not quite so simple for a jet
engine that flies and carries humans
there are two main types of jet fuel
used for commercial aviation jet a and
jet a1
jet a is primarily used in the united
states and jet a1
is used for the rest of the world so is
this just
another case of the united states
insisting on being different because
they are too stubborn to admit the rest
of the world
may just have a better system in this
case no
the primary difference between the two
is their freezing point
with jet a1 having a lower freezing
point of minus 47 degrees
versus jet a at -40 for domestic flights
within the u.s
jet a's freezing point is just fine but
for colder climates or colder
international routes
like those that fly over the arctic a
lower freezing point is needed
to prevent the fuel from turning to wax
so
a lower freezing point is desirable but
it comes at a price
the united states use jet a because it
is
cheaper to understand why we need to
understand
how crude oil is refined crude oil is
essentially just a blend of many
different hydrocarbons
all with different carbon chain lengths
we have short chain gas molecules like
methane and butane
with one to four carbon atoms in each
chain
then we have longer gasoline molecules
with chain lengths between 5 and 10
while kerosene molecules range from
around 10 to 16
we can separate each fuel type from
crude oil
thanks to these chain lengths impacting
the boiling point of each component
which allows us to separate them with
fractional distillation
we simply heat the crude oil up and pump
it into a distillation tower
the longer chain hydrocarbons liquefy
lower in the distillation tower
thanks to their lower boiling point and
when they do so
they are topped off the shorter chain
molecules will remain gaseous and
continue rising through the tower
but the tower gets gradually colder as
it rises
soon kerosene will turn to liquid and
will be removed
then gasoline and finally the lightest
methane and butane gases rise right to
the very top
so how does this explain jet a1's lower
freezing point
freezing points and boiling points are
generally linked
so jet a can lower its freezing point by
excluding hydrocarbons with longer
chains
and therefore excludes lower boiling
point molecules from the mix
jet a in comparison is less picky about
the freezing point
and can take a larger cut of this
distillate
meaning there is a broader percentage of
the crude oil that can be included
in jet a making it cheaper than jet a1
so it makes perfect sense for a country
like the united states
that doesn't need to worry that much
about low temperatures
to manufacture a cheaper wider cut fuel
for their domestic airline industry so
these are the first two properties we
need to consider
when choosing a future aviation fuel
freezing point
and cost the freezing point issue rules
out longer chain molecules like diesel
diesel-powered vehicles in canada and
alaska
actually have to cut their fuel with
kerosene to prevent fuel from freezing
in the winter months
this is the same reason a different jet
fuel jet b
is used in parts of canada and alaska
it's also known as
wide-cut fuel which gets its name
because it takes a much larger cut of
the crude oil distillate
with a mix of 30 kerosene and 70
gasoline giving it an even lower
freezing point of minus 60.
so if this wide cut fuel can be used in
engines
why isn't it used in all engines
gasoline thanks to its shorter carbon
chain lens
is too volatile for general use in
aviation
its flash point is much lower than
kerosene
flashpoint is the lowest temperature
vapors can form
from a liquid to create an ignitable
mixture in
air so low flash points make unintended
explosions and fires
much more likely not something airports
and planes are
particularly fond of the lower
temperature of vaporization
can also cause problems with vapor locks
in plumbing
where gas bubbles can form and cause
blockages
this becomes an even larger issue for
jet engines
as boiling points lower as pressure
decreases
at altitude so gasoline is not a
desirable jet fuel
for general applications the us navy and
u.s
air force even use two different
kerosene grades
for a similar reason the u.s air force
uses
jp8 which is similar to jet a1
but with the addition of corrosion
inhibitors and
anti-icing additives that are not
required for the jet a1 standard
while the us navy uses jp5 the primary
difference between the navy
and air force fuels is that the navy
fuel has a higher flash point
60 degrees versus 38 degrees this makes
it much safer to handle
during refueling operations on aircraft
carriers
and makes explosions much less likely in
the event of an attack
this was a constant worry during world
war ii
with the predominantly gasoline-powered
piston engines
fuel fires were not a rare occurrence
during the war
this is the third property we need to
consider flashpoints
but we aren't done yet we haven't even
mentioned the most obvious
energy content the primary function of
aviation fuel
is to power the aircraft this is
achieved by igniting the fuel
which raises the heat which raises the
pressure which causes airflow
to fulfill this role most efficiently we
want high
energy content we can measure the energy
content of fuel pretty easily
it's simply the heat released when a
known quantity of fuel
is burned under specific conditions
there are two
quantity measurements however energy per
unit mass
measured in megajoules per kilogram and
energy per unit
volume measured in megajoules per liter
in general
a dense fuel with a high volumetric
energy content
is desired especially for military
aircraft
that take off with their fuel tanks
filled to the brim
so volumetric energy density is a more
important metric
commercial aircraft only fill their
tanks with enough fuel to reach their
destination
with a little extra in case of emergency
but volumetric energy density
is still generally a better measurement
let's add this to our shopping list
and start looking at potential
alternative fuels
first let's look at the numbers for our
four identified properties
with a typical kerosene jet fuel cost
freezing point flashpoint and volumetric
energy density
these will be our measuring sticks for
our alternative fuels
the first stop on our proverbial
shopping trip is the biofuel oil
we have a ton of options to choose from
here
in terms of production volumes
bioethanol and biodiesel
are currently the most available
biofuels ethanol is a short chain
alcohol
similar to the short chain hydrocarbons
its freezing point and flash point is
quite low minus 115 degrees celsius
and 13 degrees respectively the low
freezing point is useful but the low
flash point
is a problem this makes ethanol volatile
which makes it undesirable as a jet fuel
its volumetric energy density is about
61
of kerosene's meaning range would be
reduced if fuel tanks remain the same
size
biodiesel suffers from the opposite
problem to bioethanol
because its carbon chain lengths are
much longer as a result
its flash point is very high between 98
and 150 degrees
depending on the feedstock used and as
expected
with a very high freezing point of about
one degree
this fuel would turn to wax in the fuel
tanks it's unusable
however we can further process these
biofuels to create fuels
that are so similar to kerosene that
they can even be used in current
generation planes with very little
modification
airbus began testing a fuel composed
entirely of biofuel
this year in an a350 powered by the
rolls-royce xwb
engines testing the plane's performance
and emissions
using the fuel which was manufactured by
nest
a company that manufactures biofuels
from palm oil and waste oils
like cooking oil results of this test
have yet to be published
but nasa has already published data from
their own tests with a 50 50 fuel blend
of traditional jet fuel and a similar
plant oil derived biofuel
their tests showed with only a 50 50
blend
that particulate emissions in the
contrail were reduced
by 70 percent that's important because
those particulates
have a much larger impact on earth's
atmosphere
than the carbon emissions this is
positive news
but these biofuels are a long way from
being cost effective
or even environmentally friendly to
manufacture
the main challenges facing biofuels are
the scaling of feedstocks
in an environmentally friendly way and
cost
waste oil products as feedstocks are
fantastic
and every country should be working on
ways to collect waste products
to feed this growing industry but
sourcing oil
from the pam industry is obviously
problematic
as the pam oil industry is driving the
destruction
of the borneo rainforest sourcing enough
feedstocks to completely replace fossil
fuels
in the aviation industry is going to be
a massive problem to solve
and right now we have no answer cost
is also a huge issue norway announced a
0.5
biofuel mandate for the aviation sector
in 2019
this is a tiny fraction of the total
fuel used
but scandinavian airlines has said that
this 0.5
mandate will add an additional 3.3
million dollars in fuel costs a
year making it 100 assuming prices
wouldn't rise with the extra demand
would cost 660 million dollars
extra a year that would completely wipe
out scandinavian airlines 2019
profit of 84 million dollars so
these biofuels currently fail the cost
metric despite being
suitable alternatives to kerosene even
if we ignore the questionable
environmental benefit of the feedstocks
the real issue here is the difficulty in
scaling up the feedstocks to meet demand
so are there any other alternatives
hydrogen
is also being explored as a potential
future fuel
airbus has published several concept
aircraft that could utilize hydrogen
because unlike biofuels hydrogen cannot
be used in existing planes
this would require a complete overhaul
of airlines plane
inventories and would cost trillions
over several years
hydrogen's main advantage is that its
feedstock is just
water and we are surrounded by water
however
hydrogen currently needs very pure fresh
water
to prevent corrosion to the electrodes
that split the water apart
during electrolysis researchers are
working on ways to extend
the life of these electrodes while
preventing the salt ions
like chloride that are found in seawater
from breaking down
the electrodes the alternative is simply
pairing the system
with a desalination process but this
would draw
even more electricity for what is
already a very expensive process
hydrogen right now does not satisfy our
cost requirement
but let's move forward with the
expectation that we will have
massive amounts of excess renewable
energy looking for a home
in the future and assume these costs
will come down
hydrogen has insanely good gravimetric
energy density
at 120 megajoules per kilogram
completely blowing kerosene out of the
water at 44 megajoules per kilogram
however hydrogen's volumetric energy
density
the quantity we actually care about is
complete dog trash the only way to get a
reasonable number is by pressurizing it
or making it cold
but even then it's volumetric energy
density
is terrible at 700 bar that 700 times
atmospheric pressure hydrogen still has
a volumetric energy density
of 5.6 megajoules per liter compared to
jet fuels
38.3 pressurizing a fuel tank to 700
bear
comes with its dangers as repeated
pressure cycles can lead to rapid
failure
due to fatigue this is made worse by
hydrogen's habit of attacking and in
brittling
materials a phenomenon that is also
accelerated
by higher pressures so most designs for
hydrogen fuel tanks
instead call for cryogenic storage where
the hydrogen
is cooled to achieve a higher volumetric
energy density
with much lower pressures this also
results in higher energy densities of 8
megajoules per liter
but still much lower than the 38
megajoules per liter of traditional
fuels
this low volumetric energy density and
the need to pressurize
makes hydrogen fuel tanks a nightmare to
integrate
into an aircraft's airframe planes these
days place a large amount of fuel inside
the wings
this is ideal for several reasons it
takes up
no useful space inside the cabin of the
plane
aircraft wings need to be hollow to
increase the strength of the wings
the weight of the fuel being located so
close to the center of lift
means the plane does not need to adjust
its control surfaces
during flight to compensate for changes
in the centre of gravity
as the fuel gets used up which reduces
drag
finally when flying wings deflect
upwards
due to the upwards lift force they
create this creates stress in the
supporting structures of the plane
so by putting the fuel in the wings it
actually helps the wings deflect less
as the weight of the fuel pushes them
down and
as the fuel is used up the lift the
wings need to generate
reduces and the upwards lift forcing the
wings up
reduces too storing the heavy fuel in
the wings
is an incredibly elegant solution and
it's not
possible with hydrogen there simply is
not enough space
in the narrow hollow structure of wings
to fit the equipment needed
this space is also getting even smaller
as newer generation composite planes
enter the market with their sleek
elegant wings being much thinner than
older metal versions
because hydrogen needs to be pressurized
and cooled it requires
specialized fuel tanks that are too
bulky to fit into these small spaces
the matter is only made worse because of
hydrogen's
dismal volumetric energy density some
designs for hydrogen planes simply call
for the mass of fuel tanks to be placed
inside the fuselage
replacing valuable space that could be
used for passengers or cargo
this just compounds the issue of cost
even more as
airlines will be now making less while
also having to pay more for fuel
while some have proposed a drastic
change in flight architecture
the blended wing the blended wing offers
fantastic drag characteristics
and leaves plenty of space within the
wing to store the large fuel tanks
there is a lot more to be said about
this design but we will explore this
kind of plane in detail in a future
video
now we need to deal with the safety
concerns
hydrogen is a gas in normal conditions
so flashpoint is not a relevant quantity
its gases are going to ignite at all
ambient temperatures
if exposed to an ignition source it is a
difficult fuel to handle for this reason
hydrogen also has no odor and its flame
is nearly invisible
so detection of leaks is difficult it's
also difficult to mix odorizing agents
like the sulfur odorants we add to
natural gas
because the freezing temperatures of
liquid hydrogen would simply turn them
solid
in the tanks and they wouldn't exit with
the gas when there was a leak
these odorants would also contaminate
any fuel cells using hydrogen to
generate electricity
this is a problem because many future
hydrogen-powered jet engines
including all of airbus concepts call
for hybrid engines
mixing electric motors powered by
hydrogen fuel cells
with combustion turbines burning
hydrogen
gas alarms will be essential early
warning systems
and they will need to be located
anywhere large quantities of hydrogen
is stored in the case of a leak modular
tanks with shut-off valves between
each section will be essential to
minimize risk
these storage and handling difficulties
are likely the largest barrier for
hydrogen moving forward
and this is why some have proposed an
extra step
that will use hydrogen to generate a new
type of hydrocarbon fuel
e-fuels this would be done by combining
carbon dioxide
which will be drawn directly from the
atmosphere using direct air capture
with hydrogen to produce methanol this
methanol would be liquid at ambient
temperatures
and could be further processed like our
ethanol from earlier
to produce kerosene e fuels e-fuels are
fuels
that are created entirely using
sustainable feedstocks
and renewable electricity this would
solve the scalability issues of biofuels
but more than likely costs a lot more
due to the sheer
amount of energy needed to both create
hydrogen
and draw carbon dioxide from the air
it's hard to make predictions on the
future of the air travel industry
but if i was placing my bets i think
biofuel mandates
despite their questionable environmental
benefit
will continue to be introduced and then
as
excess renewable electricity floods the
market
energy-intensive processes like e-fuels
may take over
primarily because these fuels are
compatible with current jet engines
hydrogen has a chance of succeeding but
it will require
massive investments to completely
overhaul airport
and plane architectures which alone will
cost trillions of dollars
this cost barrier is going to be
something the aviation industry
is going to have to accept in the near
term
it's more than likely that air travel
will get vastly more expensive
during this transitional period that
cost inflation
can be minimized by a gradual
introduction of biofuels and e-fuels
that are compatible with current
generation infrastructure
however as we saw in norway even a 0.5
biofuel mandate increased fuel costs
significantly
and this may just be a hard truth we as
a society
need to accept if we truly want to
become a carbon neutral civilization
and save our planet that the aviation
industry's
historic decline in ticket prices may be
beginning
to reverse there is one facet to the
future of aviation fuel
that i have not mentioned in this video
the electric future
there are several small planes already
flying
powered by batteries their ranges are
severely limited
but a niche market could be developing
for them in the near future
this is a topic my friend sam from
wendover productions
covers in detail in his video why
electric planes are inevitably
coming you can watch that right now on
nebula
the streaming service sam and i created
together along with a hundred other
youtube creator friends
on nebula you can watch all of my videos
ad free
and sponsorship free you can watch
original series like my logistics of
d-day series
or wendover's fantastic originals like
the very good trivia
show where you can see how much sam and
i actually hate each other
71 plus 34 71 plus 34
34 is 105. uh you didn't get it
right before it was right at the time or
something correct one plus 57
i know or you can watch something made
by someone i actually like
like neo's mesmerizing original called
the unknown city
with out of this world blender
animations of a fictional city
being used for innovative data
visualization on the world
refugee crisis you can sign up for
nebula directly
but thanks to our sponsor you can get
all of that for free
when you sign up to curiositystream with
the link in the description
you can sign up for the insanely low
price of 14.79 a year
or 299 a month this is by far the best
way to support this channel
and the content we make curiosity stream
sponsorships
have allowed us to hire new animators
writers and more
to continue upping our game and that's
really thanks to all of you
signing up to watch their award-winning
documentaries
like this one called a world without
nasa
a two-part series that explores some of
the world-changing technologies that
nasa has introduced to the world
curiosity stream is well worth the 1479
price
alone which is 26 off the usual price of
19.99
but with your subscription you are
helping to support
not just my channel but over a hundred
other channels that are part of nebula
a streaming service that we own and
control outside of the whims of the
youtube algorithm
a sandbox for us to experiment with our
craft
with one-off documentaries longer form
videos
topics that weren't formed around a
catchy title and thumbnail
and series that cover topics that get
flagged in the youtube algorithm
like my world war ii series which will
continue later this year
with the logistics of the battle of
britain so please sign up and help
independent educational creators and get
some excellent documentaries
and videos as a reward if you are
looking for something else to watch
right now
why not watch real science's latest
video on the insane biology of the
platypus
a strange egg-laying mammal or watch my
last video
detailing the problems with ethanol
biofuels